well you know speaking of cartoons and
animation and topical uh we end up
seeing the new spite of us this weekend
oh [__] I'm actually seeing it tonight
you're seeing it tonight oh yeah okay
yeah it was incredible I think visually
it was a feast I think even like too
good at points really because yeah
because I I was I'm watching it tonight
so I was like and it's been a while
since I've seen the first one and Aki's
never seen it so I was just like let me
like refresh myself before I watch the
second movie yeah goddamn that first
movie [__] amazing I always forget
how [__] amazing that show I think we
both said the first one we liked more
yes okay I like the first one more I
think I like the first one more just
because the first one visually was like
it was incredible yeah
um and it kind of like showed me
something that I guess I'd never really
seen before like the best way I can
describe this is just like you know like
did you guys ever see the Matrix at all
yeah like when like when it came out
though you know when it was like three
years yeah I was like five
that's what I was trying to say you know
when the Matrix first came out it was
such like a visual Revolution it kind of
revolutionized visual effects Revolution
shut the [__] up Joey I swear to god
stop with your dad jokes for a second
Joey I'm trying to make a point here
nice one Joe thank you
but I like you know before the Matrix
came out no one had ever seen something
like the Matrix and you know bullet time
became a thing you know became the slow
motion effects whenever we see this
bullet time effect in kind of like
movies we'd be like ah it was like it's
the Matrix effect yeah it's the bullet
time effect that came from the Matrix
that's kind of how I felt watching the
first spider verse there was not there
had been that nothing
nothing had been released before that
had given me the visual sensation that's
the original spider-verse had given me
and it blew my [__] mind the point
where now I see like something like Puss
in Boots like two visually [__]
spectacular but I'm like well
in spite of us did it first you know as
far as you know the story was so good
this story was really good but I'm like
visually I'm like I've seen this kind of
I've seen this kind of visual style
before and what I'm like ah they
obviously got they seem like they were
heavily influenced by what spiderverse
had laid out for them I'm not saying
it's just like oh spider-verse is better
than everything I'm just saying visually
it that that kind of laid the groundwork
yeah and spider-verse 2 definitely took
things a step further it's it [__]
everything up it up everything to a
point where my brain did not have enough
time to process everything that was
happening
the way I described it was it's
literally like watching a movie with
Subway Surfers in the corner
there's like seven Subway Surfers
there's so much happenings Subway Surfer
the movie he's like almost almost went
to a detriment at times like I wish for
some scenes they would just let it
breathe yeah right but there's just too
many moments and like sometimes there'd
be a lot of text on screen and you can't
[__] read it yeah it's so [__]
fast and you're like yeah hold up pause
hold on and slow down was it good though
like oh yeah it was amazing but it just
it just I think it would benefit a
little bit from slowing down right yeah
at that point there were points where
there were so many things going on I'm
like my brain needs to slow down to
process everything that is happening and
then even even when there are some more
serious story moments they're like okay
let's just change the color of the scene
for every single cut and I'm like yo can
you slow down for just a second all
right so they did a JoJo yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but they just
didn't do it every [__] frame yeah
yeah yeah yeah there is no time to
breathe in this movie at all and you
know it's it's a good thing but when
it's like you know but I think my brain
can process it in the first film because
it was like an hour and a half or
something this is two hours and 20
minutes and it it puts it puts its foot
on the gas from like minute five to
minute uh two hour 200 uh two hour two
two hour twenty right you know it never
takes forth the gas and I'm like holy
[__] I I am I am exhausted Jesus all
right it is it is insane uh yeah and I
think like the story as well is a little
bit more like the first film was a
little bit more simple to follow along
with this one there's like oh here's
like 20 different characters and 20
different worlds doing 20 different
things and
and then we're gonna connect it all into
one career and storyline I'm like I've
already like that I really enjoyed that
this is it's just a lot it's it's a lot
to keep the only thing the only thing I
know in this second spider the first
film is they do they pay the homage to
the 60 Spider-Man memes quite a bit
right
they they play they pay homage to a lot
of things I got a lot of different
spider verses and you can probably take
an entire [__] textbook and just just
to write about it basically but yeah
excited I'm excited to see it yeah I
think I think it's a film I definitely
need to see a second time just to fully
appreciate it yeah I I'm I I'm gonna
most certainly have to watch the next
one again before I watch the the one
after it at some point yeah oh yeah for
sure yeah it's it's a lot to process and
it's it makes me happy just to see you
know people that are passionate about
their work it's it's one of those films
where it's it's rare just to watch like
a piece of media and just to feel like
holy [__] the people really care they
they [__] cared oh yeah about making
the is good they actually absolutely
yeah everyone did not have to go that
hard but they did anyway yeah and I like
I like normally my problem with
Spider-Man like as a character I I don't
actually find kind of boring but I like
I like miles a lot Spiderman I think
he's really fun no I agree I really like
what'd you find about what'd you find
boring about the Spider-Man character
well maybe this is because I watched the
Andrew Garfield ones last time okay
okay there
is kind of like uh he's
deaf actor is what I would kind of
describe him as he's kinda he's not the
most emotive right I guess it's kind of
like fun Nostalgia when I watched the
90s like 2000s yeah yeah for sure but
like I don't I I don't know well because
of it I've never really found Spider-Man
as engaging as say Batman both of them
sounds so [__] dumb thing about
Spider-Man
my grandma and I always found were way
more compelling as a character he's like
edgy and dark well I think it's because
as well like goat for actors
Maguire films especially I feel maybe
it's because like it was still during
that era where like the Superman uh
sorry not Superman like superhero films
were still very much in like the cut and
dry like superhero styled like classic
Spider-Man every other character was
more interesting than Spider-Man
yeah I mean for me personally yeah until
recently we've started the villains are
way more interesting than yeah I I think
I think in spite of us does a good
portrayal I just you know telling a
story of what Spider-Man is meant to be
uh like have you played the Spider-Man
Insomniac games at all no they're
already
oh well you you have one now yeah I'm
gonna [__] play Spider-Man yeah I I I
think I think the insomnia guy uh the
insomnia games does a very very good job
at portraying the kind of the kind of
character uh that Spider-Man's meant to
be uh because I think Toby Maguire I
agree I really do love the original
Spider-Man movies but to people guys
just a little bit flat to me
um like Spider-Man's always meant to
have meant to have had this kind of like
arrogance a little I like him though
you know a little bit of quirkiness to
him and everything like that which if it
was Rob Pattinson Spiderman well that's
just yours
like my favorite Spider-Man was the
Spider-Man I grew up with which is like
the original 90s Spider-Man cartoon that
is that to me like the OG goaded
Spider-Man the big difference between
Spider-Man and Batman to me was I felt
like I could actually relate to
Spider-Man as a character or as Batman
was always just this super uber cool
thing that was more relatable to
Spider-Man uh all about Spider-Man for
you the fact that he delivers pizzas
compared to the both you know how do I
relate more to a teenage superhero who's
just trying his best to live a double
life and just trying to get the [__]
girl that he likes or a [__]
billionaire playboy with dead parents I
don't know which one do I relate more to
that's just [__] no I actually
studied martial arts as well with uh
with what's his name
[Music]
what's the actor called who plays him
again the Irish guy taken which uh oh
Liam Neeson I was like which iteration
are we talking about yes The Shadow
Society
I want to be trained train me
I don't know you know man the parents
are hard in the Limelight but
Spider-Man's crushing it lately
Tom Holland's a good Spider-Man
um yeah yeah I mean like yeah Batman's
always been just like even as a kid I
was like this is a bit too edgy for me
it's no I loved Batman love Batman
you're a Batman were you a Batman kid
the world of Gotham is the most
interesting out of all the I agree like
I think that Spider-Man is like New York
[Applause]
pizza's like it's Chicago mixed with
London mixed with New York it's kind of
like mixed with him yeah it's kind of
this weird [__] up world that's really
cool and dark and grungy yeah yeah I
found it more interesting as a concept
that's just like such a small
neighborhood I've also just found like
the Batman films to just be more
interesting and well-made films compared
to the Spider-Man films I mean they had
the more in my taste I feel I mean The
Dark Knight trilogy [__] okay the dog
night trilogy is I think the only one
I'm super like emotionally attached to
oh look Batman Begins I mean that that
was good enough to like carry the whole
goddamn but I feel like I liked the Dark
Knight series just because it was like
it was a crime Thriller with people who
dressed up in a bat suit are you telling
me but also you don't like the George
Clooney Batman okay okay hold on with
Arnold Schwarzenegger and the animated
series was insanely goaded I watched it
I it was so [__] good that is good my
camel's the joker as well in that who is
this is one of the best performances in
like voiceover history it's so [__]
good everyone went hard I just I just
never like I I never liked it as a kid I
don't know what what why didn't you if
you like this Spider-Man one you would
have loved the Batman one no because I
did watch both I watched both the
Spider-Man animated series and The
Batman series
um I I think maybe that's why I didn't
like it was like really really grounded
and a bit too like Noir kind of like
feeling for me yeah I think I think I
just like I I think I first discovered
like the Batman uh cartoons and like you
know the early Batman films during a
time where I was just like oh I like
edgy stuff whereas I looked at
Spider-Man I was like that's for
children
hello hello
I remember my favorite Spider-Man Arc
and This Is Me Maybe maybe this isn't
this shouldn't be a surprise to anyone
any in any way shape or form but my
favorite Spider-Man Arc from the
original animated series was
um The Arc where she he meets like The
Madam Webb or something like that and he
has to pick a bunch of superheroes to
transport to this other world to have
this [__] massive like war between
superheroes and super villains so I'm
like wait a minute this is uh I just
realized this is a [__] easy guy
that's why you love Spider-Man
okay
it wasn't all about the attic ground
baking animation or anything he just
likes because it's an Issa guy maybe
I've maybe I've never grown up maybe
I've just liked the same things I've
liked as a kid all along I also just
realized like this far into this
discussion that this is literally every
discussion in every comic book store
across the world like it's like what's
better Spider-Man no Batman Okay hear me
out that man into the spot of us uh yeah
sorry sorry
man into the spider-verse yeah they go
into other worlds it's cool I like
Crisis across infinite Earths because it
has like other so what you're telling me
is if they brought out a Batman that's
an issachar you would like it
I mean there is that like I said it's
it's the arc where um I think I think
it's called yeah it does I think it's a
Justice League Arc it's like Crisis
across across infinite Earths I think
that I found I'm not uh I'm not a big
comic book person but there is my
favorite arcs were always the ones where
they cross over into like the other
worlds and the other Multiverse and the
Batmans meet the other Batmans and the
other Supermans meet the other Supermans
yeah that's that hey hey what can I say